Two young men started their journey in
Bitcoin last year. One worked 12 hours a
day staring at charts, chasing every
green candle. Last night, a single whale
trap wiped out his entire account. The
other man, he spent his evening with his
family, sipped a coffee, and woke up to
a $5,000 profit. The difference wasn't
luck. It was the system. One was
hunting, the other was defending. Most
traders fail because they think trading
is about buying. It's not. It's about
not falling for the traps. In the BTC
market, you are being hunted by
institutions. Without a shield, your
emotions become your worst enemy. You
feel the FOMO. You click by and the trap
snaps. Trap defense. BTC changes
everything. Our engine visualizes the
invisible traps of the whales. We teach
you the most powerful skill in the
world, the discipline to do nothing 70%
of the time. When you finally move, you
move with 90% certainty. It's
highresolution defense for a highstakes
market. Don't be the trader who loses it
all. Be the one who stays protected.
Activate your defense protocol below.
Welcome to the academy.